leben im all ein einziges gen führt zum
tod und eine neue start technik auf
flugzeugträgern das sind nur drei der
fünf themen heute in den kriegs und 51
sentinel tui hat jetzt die ersten bilder
zur erde geschickt innerhalb von maximal
zehn tagen kann der satellit jeden
einzelnen fleck auf der erde
aufzeichnung mehr leser erreichen dann
die informationen geostationäre
satelliten
diese wiederum schicken die daten weiter
an vier bodenstationen vor zwei wochen
in den krieg zum top five news hatten
wir von dem raketenstart in kourou
berichtet die europäische kommission und
die esa möchten bis 2021 ganze zehn
satelliten paare ins weltall befördern
jeder einzelne satellit ist speziell auf
ein themengebiet ausgerichtet da eine
ober beobachtet die oberflächen der
länder und meere der andere
temperaturdifferenzen oder spurengase
aerosole oder den meeresspiegel wie auch
der erste 2014 gestarteten satelliten
lenko man hat der letzte satellit der
nach oben geschossen wurde intellektuell
die zielvorgabe des kopernikus projektes
mit den bildern der satelliten sollen
umweltkrisen erklärt und bekämpft werden
können vor allem die präventive arbeit
soll mit den daten der satelliten
erleichtert werden auf den jetzt
veröffentlichten bildern kann man den
norden europas kaum erkennen dicke
wolken bedecken diesen die esa stellte
daher erstmal nur bilder von der
italienischen poebene und der riviera
online 2016 sein neuer satellit ins all
gebracht werden
der in der hälfte der zeit die erde
abbilden kann
wir berichteten schon häufig vor einer
mission rosetta herzstück der mission
ist ja viele cds ein kleines
hochtechnologisches labor das letzte
november auf dem kometen schule gelandet
ist vor fünf tagen verkündete der
forscher max will es von der universität
cardiff neues über den kometen 67 petrow
gerasimenko die rolle von oracle so
zeitig veröffentlichte seine
erkenntnisse es sollen lebende
mikroorganismen
dort hausen schury wäre für diese sogar
ein um einiges angenehmer lebensraum als
die antarktis oder axis aufgrund von
früheren beobachtungen vermuten die
wissenschaftler schon länger dass es auf
julie lebendige organismen geben müsse
ein komet wie dieser würde eigentlich
reflektieren sie tut das nicht die
ursache glauben die forscher bereits
gefunden zu haben
organisches material also leben letzte
aufnahmen touris zeigen große krater
unter der kometenoberfläche wären
unterirdische hohlräume die nach und
nach brüchig werden und zusammenbrechen
mikroorganismen würden daran mit schuld
sein
der bisher nicht belegbaren theorie zur
folge steige die aktivität der lebewesen
und somit auch die krater bildung je
näher zum aufgang der sonne kommt desto
aktiver würden sich eben auch die krater
bilden in den letzten monaten bereitete
fiel er immer wieder schwierigkeiten
erst landete das labor mehr oder weniger
unkontrolliert und dann konnte kein
kontakt zu viel hergestellt werden dass
durch sonnenenergie betriebene labor
verkeilte sich vermutungen zufolge
zwischen schatten spendenden felsspalten
die gespeicherte energie reichte nicht
mehr lange um informationen an die
bodenstation zu schicken
der kontakt brach ab erst nach wochen
erreichten wieder vereinzelte
sonnenstrahlen viele überraschend
meldete sich das kleine labor bei ihren
besitzern zurück der mikrobiologe wandel
m von der northwestern university in
chicago hat zusammen mit seinen
arbeitskollegen im nature communications
magazin eine von ihnen durchgeführte
studie zur pest vorgestellt sie
untersuchten die früher weit verbreitete
und todbringende pest in medizinischen
kreisen wird sie auch jahre sinja pestis
genannt der name stammt von dem
vorgänger bakterium der pest ja sinja
pseudo tuberculosis der vorgänger führte
nicht zwingend beziehungsweise so gut
wie nie zum tod sondern vielmehr zu
stoffwechselstörungen durchfall und so
weiter lief das bakterium hervor wie
wird aus einem durchfall bakterium ein
tödliches der frage sind die forscher in
ihrer studie nachgegangen sie prüften in
experimenten ihre these
sie gingen davon aus dass ein einziges
gehen schon die antwort darauf liefern
kann ja sehen ja pseudo tuberkulose
setzte sich hauptsächlich nur im darm
traktes menschen nieder
im gegensatz zum pest-bakterium breite
sie sich
dieses nicht über den ganzen körper auf
die pest schon die experten konnten
uralte pest mikroben untersuchen und
stellten folgendes fest die mikroben
vermehrten sich nicht nur im darm trakt
sondern auch in anderen bereichen aber
es zeigte sich keine tödliche wirkung
als sie diese mit noch nicht ganz so
alten proben gegenüber stellten kamen
sie der antwort ein ganzes stück näher
das sogenannte lagen konnte nur in den
jüngeren mikroben gefunden werden
dieses wäre verantwortlich für die
tödliche wirkung in der mathematik wird
häufig eine gegenprobe gemacht um das
ergebnis zu überprüfen
die wissenschaftler führten diese an
mäusen durch plagen und uralte pest
mikroben das bedeutete tod die
gegenprobe bestätigte die these dass da
gehen nimmt einfluss auf die tödliche
wirkung aber alexander ranking vom
max-planck von pettenkofer institut in
münchen zur folge gebe es aber auch
tödliche pass mikroben ohne dass klar
gehen
trotz des großen schrittes steht die
forschung also noch ganz am anfang
viele von euch die er nicht so besonders
viel wert auf ordnung und ständiges
aufräumen legen werden bestimmt schon
einmal den folgenden satz hören bekommen
haben oder vielleicht schon jetzt gesagt
haben ordnung braucht nur der dumme
das genie beherrscht das chaos so einmal
albert einstein jemand der regelmäßig
aufräumt und ordnung schafft ist
deswegen aber geben bestimmt nicht dumm
doch laut einer neuen studie gibt es
tatsächlich starke unterschiede zwischen
den menschen die ordentlich sind und
denen die es nicht sind
in einer studie von casting-shows und
der university of minnesota führten die
forscher mehrere experimente zu dem
thema durch
es wurden zwei büroräume eingerichtet
also die räume diese aussagen die
büroräume mit der eine war sehr
ordentlich und aufgeräumt der andere war
mehr oder weniger pures chaos im ersten
versuch sollten die probanden einen
fragebogen ausfüllen nach der einführung
dürften sich die teilwahl aussuchen ob
und wie viel sie für eine wohltätige
organisation oder ähnliche spenden
wollten
zusätzlich mussten sie zwischen einem
apfel und einem schokoriegel als kleinen
happen zwischendurch entscheiden
diejenigen die im ordentlichen büro
saßen griffen viel häufiger zum
schokoriegel und spendeten weniger als
die anderen wer in chaos gearbeitet
hatte spendete jede menge von seinem
eigenen geld und ließ sich den apfel
schmecken
also in ordnung hat etwas mit sozialer
einstellung und gesünderer ernährung zu
tun
ein weiterer versuch beschäftigte sich
mit tennisbällen die aufgabe war
möglichst neue verwendungszwecke für
einen solchen ball zu finden
hier konnten beide parteien überzeugen
sowohl die aus dem chaos büro als auch
die anderen glänzen mit hervorragender
kreativität aber die neuen
verwendungszwecke von den probanden aus
dem unordentlichen büro wurden von den
forschern als wesentlich interessanter
angesehen chaos schafft also demnach
einfallsreichtum oder die leute haben
irgendetwas damit zu tun ob sich die
unterschiedlichen einrichtungen auch auf
das entdecken von neuen dingen auswirkt
wurde im dritten test geprüft sie
dürften sich zwischen einem neuen und
einem schon länger erprobten gegenstand
entscheiden ordnung schnappte sich
altbekanntes chaos das neue spannende
wer in ordnung lebt lässt sich also
nicht so schnell auf neues ein
das forscherteam möchte jetzt
herausfinden ob sich die gleichen
resultate auch in der virtuellen welt
zeigen beispielsweise auf webseiten
wenn die webseite ordentlich ist verhält
man sich dann auch demnach der
amerikanische werk konzern huntington
ingalls industries hat einen neustart
hilfe technik entwickelt die es
ermöglichen soll in erhöhter
taktfrequenz flugzeuge von einem
flugzeugträger starten zu lassen herz
der technik magnetismus eine etwa 100
meter lange magnet schiene soll die
flugzeug in kürzester zeit auf 260
kilometer pro stunde beschleunigen und
das klappt tatsächlich bisher wurden
jets mit komprimierten dampf auf die
stadt geschwindigkeit von rund 260
kilometer gebracht der in einer schiene
untergebrachte kolben bei dieser technik
wird am vordersten ende mit wasserdampf
gefüllt beim start löst sich der
zylinder des kolbens und der druck
schießt das flugzeug sozusagen vom deck
ohne eine solche unterstützung würde der
staat auf einer unter 200 meter langen
startbahn ein enormes risiko für pilot
und maschine darstellen
das elektromagnetik aircraft launch
sytem treibt mit magnetismus seinen
schritten an die technik an sich ist
eigentlich nicht neu sie wird bereits
schon in einigen freizeitparks in etwas
abgeänderter form bei achterbahn
eingesetzt der schlitten ist aber hier
kein personenwagen sondern ein kampfjet
oder eben ähnliches huntington ingalls
industries stellte ihr system auf die
probe es sollte einen 40 tonnen schwere
metall wagen auf startgeschwindigkeit
bringen bei dem resultat könnte man von
einem leichten spiel reden auf dem
flugzeugträger george vor ort
installierten sie ihre technik und wie
zu erwarten
die 40 tonnen wurden problemlos vom
flugzeugträger geschossen der wagen hob
ab und flog davon das war aber auch
nicht die zielvorgabe die zielvorgabe
von einem anderen projekt lautete hyper
oder überschallgeschwindigkeit welche
resultate die us airforce schon
erreichen konnte erfahrt ihr hier im
video oben überschallgeschwindigkeit ist
im kommen zu rap und zum block kommt ihr
hier unten
und wie ist es bei euch am arbeitsplatz
wie sieht's so aus im eigenen zimmer
chaotisch oder ordentlich und könnt ihr
die ergebnisse der studie bestätigen
oder seit der super kreativ und super
ordentlich oder umgekehrt lasst es uns
in den kommentaren wissen und ansonsten
bis dann bleib dran